marioupol est-il sur le point de tomber
ce port stratégique sur la mer d'azov
est l'objectif numéro un de l'armée
russe objet d'un constant pilonnage sur
place plus d'un millier de soldats
ukrainiens se sont rendus aux forces
russes entre 20 et 22 mille personnes y
sont mortes depuis le début de la guerre
d'après les autorités locales
reste à savoir maintenant évidemment
comment la situation va évoluer sur
place on va plus loin on va tout de
suite évidemment en débattre avec dans
un instant à mes côtés bruno daroux et
asia de l'imam zyad limam qui nous
rejoint en plateau également à bruno
daroux bas c'est ce qui s'appelle une
entrée dans le champ et comme on dit en
télévision bonjour bruno daroux
merci d'être avec nous bonjour et de
l'imam d'afrique magazine marioupol je
disais sur le point de tomber si
effectivement cette information se
vérifier en tout cas ce qu'annonce le
ministère de la défense déjà des
défections au sein de l'armée
ukrainienne environ un millier d'hommes
si c'était le cas évidemment ces actes
aurel la partition du pays voulu par
moscou bruno daroux oui parce que
marioupol et depuis le début de cette
tentative d'invasion par la russie un
objectif stratégique pourquoi on l'a dit
déjà plusieurs reprises parce que
évidemment c'est le grand port du sud ça
permettrait la continuité territoriale
entre la partie dont basse et puis le
lien vers la crimée voire plus à l'est
à l'ouest
peut-être vers au dessin ça on ne sait
pas encore donc ça c'est le premier
intérêt le deuxième intéressant c'est
celle au grand port sur la mer d'azov
donc ça permettrait le contrôle par les
russes de la mer d'azov et
accessoirement d'ailleurs le fait
d'empêcher des bateaux il très bien de
quitter le port de marioupol avec
notamment des chargements en double et
donc c'est à un objectif très important
que vladimir poutine mènera jusqu'au
bout malheureusement il n'en est pas
loin ça laisse entière via l'imam là la
question des pertes humaines l'ukraine
est une vaste scène de crime voilà ce
que déclare le progrès la cour pénale
internationale
en visite aujourd'hui à abuja faut-il
que les les autorités françaises à leur
tour se rendent sur place et par
autorités françaises évidemment on pense
au président de la république oui alors
là il se trouve qu'on peut pas tout
faire à 0 peut pas faire une élection
présidentielle allait à bout de chat là
je pense que le timing français et et
plus partis sauf aguerris deviez sauf
allier les deux et peut-être
je pense aussi que la france a une
position un petit peu intermédiaire
c'est vraiment maintenant décanale
d'ouverture et c'est assumé en disant
d'ailleurs que si on maintenait passé
canal d'ouverture on prendrait le risque
d'avoir une présidence russe qui serait
plus en face c'était quand même assez
assez particulier comme message serre si
on lui parle pas il risque de s'isoler
encore plus c'est de croire encore plus
à ses profs d'histoire donc je pense pas
que moi et puis la france a fait des
gestes il ya des enquêteurs criminels
qui sont à bout de champ donc je pense
pas que la visite elle même soit
d'actualité aujourd'hui peut-être un
ministre avant mais comme on est
maintenant drivée par un parent
un contexte intérieur très très fort
chaque déplacement chaque geste va
prendre une importance particulière et
encore une fois je ne sais pas on n'est
pas dans le secret de l'elysée là sur
ces histoires
après on évoque voilà la venue de la
seule chose qui est fortement souhaitée
il ya un moment est-ce que ça va pas se
voir une amie mais aussi est ce que le
fait d'aller là bas est ce que cette des
douanes aussi je dis bon d'aller marcher
boris johnson a fait son moment il est
allé marcher dans les rues de kiev est
ce que ça change dramatiquement et le
rapport de force militaire est le
rapport de force politique j'en sais
rien franchement je pense que c'est il
faut être solidaire ça c'est sûr est-ce
que c'est par des moments de j'allais
dire de
de mise en scène politique très
puissante est ce que ce oui peut-être
franchement je ne sais pas par contre
militairement c'est là que c'est la
question se pose aujourd'hui comme ça
sert et ce qu'on livre des armes quel
type d'armes ont livré ce qu'on va vers
la coupe belligérance est ce qu'on va
pas vers la co belligérance jusqu'à quel
point on s'engage ça c'est des vrais
questions oui non et sur la visite juste
par ailleurs effectivement bruce johnson
y est allé manger ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne donc il y allait s
qualité prix visent britannique pour la
revanche dans l'air voilà où cela
s'avère la vienne y est allé alors on
peut pas exclure
on peut rien exclure à quelques jours du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'était peut-être un joli
coup de voilà deux des manuels macrom
enfin bon prendront peut-être aussi à
des accusations voilà donc pas sûr qu'il
y aille et on n'est pas dans le secret
des dieux mais c'est vrai que il a quand
même dit emmanuel macron qu'il irait si
sa venue pouvait être utile servir à
faire avancer quelque chose d'un point
de vue diplomatique de négociation et
c'est y aller pour y aller d'après ce
qu'il a dit en fait il n'en voit pas
trop l'intérêt finalement de quel côté
va pencher la france pour leurs
solidaire de ses alliés pour sanctionner
la russie de vladimir poutine paris
pourrait relâcher un peu la pression sur
moscou c'est en tout cas ce qu'on peut
retenir de la conférence de presse de
marine le pen la candidate au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle avait
fini par admettre les crimes de guerre
commis en ukraine elle s'oppose
néanmoins aux sanctions qu'elle juge
trop pénalisante pour les français et
plaident déjà pour un rapprochement
otan-russie une fois la guerre en
ukraine terminé écouter tel que la
guerre russo ukrainienne sera achevée et
aura été réglé par un traité de paix je
me prononcerai en faveur de la mise en
oeuvre d'un rapprochement stratégique
entre l'otan et la russie comme cela
avait été naguère envisagée c'est
l'intérêt de la france et de l'europe
mais aussi je crois des états unis qui
n'ont même dans l'hypothèse une
réticence de washington à envisager une
europe de lisbonne à vladivostok
aucun intérêt à voir émerger une étroite
union sino-russe elle vraiment bien le
moment où l'imam en pleine guerre en
ukraine et alors qu'on voit là on est
tous les jours des idées va être
vraisemblablement des crimes de guerre
commis sur place non mais elle est dans
une cohérence c'est pas quelque chose
qui est nouveau est c'est une cohérence
de positionnement idéologique c'est dans
cette famille idéologique on pense que
l'alliance avec la russie est une
alliance stratégique à long terme et qui
folie faut faire en sorte qu'elles ce
qu'elle serait qu'elle se retrouve
quelque part sur le chemin devant alors
ils sont obligés de considérer les fêtes
sur le terrain en ukraine ils sont
obligés de dire qui a crime de guerre
ils sont obligés de prendre des
distances mais bon la réalité ces voix
là et puis lorsque moi ce que je trouve
intéressant dans cette conférence de
presse d'avant c'est qu'elle a fait un
long discours avant lui quoique ce soit
c'est très scripté tout ça après d'aller
nous expliquer ce qui est dans l'intérêt
des états unis je trouve que bon certes
ou peut-être elle se force un peu quand
même hein c'est on sent que au sens
qu'il faut donner des arguments il faut
faire les américains les américains ont
tout à fait mis en facteur le fait
qu'ils sont dans un long conflit avec la
chine que ce long conflit qui pas un
conflit militaire mais peut-être mais
qui est un conflit commercial
économiques culturels politiques
contrôle de l'asie et a donc c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas ça qui va
l'équivalent et leur faire penser que et
puis oui parce qu'en fait la thèse de
marine le pen c'est de dire si on se met
à dos aujourd'hui les russes ils
rejoindront les chinois en fait c'est
symbolique dans leurs beats de la chimie
mais bon renforceront la chine ça
changera pas le
paradigme américain sur cette question
et puis cette approche de la liez pas de
l'alliance stratégique avec là aussi
c'est aussi son regard sur l'europe tout
est connecté
évidemment qu'elle est plus proche de
deux dames d'un d'une main monsieur or
ban que que d'un monsieur olaf scholz ou
que d'un monsieur macron alors sa vision
européenne envie revenir dans un instant
mais mais pour autant sur la question de
l'otan bruno daroux on l'aura bien noté
marine le pen n'entend pas quitter
l'alliance atlantique n'ont à leur
écoute et le commandement intégré de
l'otan ou alors ce que c'est un clin
d'oeil un peu électoraliste aux
électeurs gaulliste puisque finalement
reviendrait à la situation qu'elle
connaît la france entre 1966 et 2009
d'ailleurs là elle l'a souligné bon
c'est essentiellement symbolique parce
que vu la merde on fonctionne
aujourd'hui l'otan finalement ça
changerait pas énormément de choses à
l'adduction ne serait pas la france de
continuer à être loyal avec l'otan et
que la france évidemment continueraient
d'appliquer l'article 5 qui est donc
l'article qui prévoit qu'en cas d'
attaque contre l'un des états de
l'alliance toutes les alliances réagi la
france serait fidèle à ça mais on voit
bien derrière tout ça en fait que ce
soit sur l'otan ou sur l'union
européenne que ce qu'elle veut mettre en
avant quand même c'est le point de vue
des nationaux comme elle dit on peut
dire des nationalistes vers la nation
d'abord la france à la répéter est une
grande puissance qui compte encore il
faut qu'on retrouve à notre souveraineté
nos moyens de défense elle a été très
dur on va peut-être en parler aussi
l'union européenne elle était quand même
très dur avec avec l'allemagne quand
même voilà alors voilà maintenant tiens
oui et non on pense à l'est de l'europe
ensemble on sent très bien le sens très
bien en fait le discours à étages serre
que là on est dans une campagne
électorale
elle doit faire face
aux accusations régulière qu'elle y
connaît rien que les lislois elle doit
faire face aux accusations régulière
qu'elle est un semi agents de moscou
qu'elle à elle ses finances et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs sont allés un
rapprochement au temps ou si c'est juste
parce que rafael vous dire avec le
timing forcément ça va être utilisée
quand elle puisqu'elle est accusé m mais
pour elle essaie de le mettre dans un
les gobelins des terres la chine
l'amérique et et puis il ya les
fondamentaux du lepénisme dur de
l'extrême droite qui sont juste derrière
l'europe des nations une europe des
nations est incompatible l'europe des
nations qu'elle imagine c'est pas
l'europe de l'union européenne et c'est
pas le fonctionnement de l'otan
aujourd'hui donc forcément ça posera des
problèmes et je pense quand même que
leurs objectifs à moyen long terme c'est
quand même de démanteler ces
organisations supranationales qui limite
la souveraineté comme tu le disais et
qui pour revenir à cette idée de
souveraineté qui qui est la primus inter
pares et après c'est quoi quand elle dit
la france est une grande puissance
faudrait oui on est pas on n'est pas le
dernier de la classe mais on est un pays
de 60 millions d'habitants avec un droit
de veto au conseil de sécurité
et surtout l'armé nucléaire et des
moyens militaires de proches projetable
on n'est pas nombreux
aujourd'hui avoir cette capacité de
projection militaire faut juste ajoute
les et sur le oui pardon non dernière
chose il se trouve que si elle était
élue chef de l'état même si elle n'avait
pas une majorité à l'assemblée elle
serait quand même d'un chef des armées
oui et puis d'où l'importance du
discours qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui
oui d'abord livre qu'elle a tenu
aujourd'hui elle sait qu'elle a un
déficit un peu de crédibilité sur ces
questions nous sommes chacun et que
l'actualité et dont deux de ces
dernières semaines et il fallait qu avec
elle essaye de combler un peu son
handicap c'est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
a essayé de faire mais cela dit que sur
les sur l'union européenne alors la
changer par rapport à 2010 est enfin
allé un peu comme un mauvais élève qui
va en classe un peu contraint et forcé
toutes les mesures qu'elle propose en
fait vont créer quand même avant
l'explosion un foutoir au sein de
l'union européenne assez considérable en
parler parce qu'au-delà effectivement du
maintien au sein de l'otan non plus du
commandement unifié on l'a compris il ya
effectivement se maintient au sein
l'union européenne plus question donc de
phr exit 1 comme elle évoquait en 2017
jusqu'au ce jusqu'au second tour en fait
un pas de quoi convaincre en tout cas
emmanuel macron puisque pour le
président sortant son adversaire défend
un projet incompatible avec
l'appartenance à l'ue écoutez le
entre le projet que je défends est celui
de la candidate d'extrême droite les
choses sont claires la candidate
d'extrême droite propose un projet
nationaliste ce qui n'est pas le
patriotisme ce projet nationaliste et je
lui dis ici à quelques mètres de là où
françois mitterrand a prononcé ces mots
parmi les derniers de son dernier mandat
le nationalisme c'est la guerre et donc
oui le projet de l'extrême droite c'est
un projet de sortie du conseil de
l'europe c'est à dire de notre socle de
valeurs et de droit sortir du conseil de
l'europe c'est sortir de l'union
européenne puisqu'elle en est la
constitution le principe fondateur il a
raison un joli même c'est incompatible
est sûre avec marine le pen mardi on a
un modèle qu'on a construit pendant 50
ans 60 ans qui est une europe à tendance
j'ai dis pas qu'elle est fédéraliste
mais à tendance
au de plus en plus de fonctions sont
gérés par l'europe de plus en plus de
thèmes sont gérés par l'europe on est
passé du charbon l'acier maintenant
c'est toute notre vie ça va de la prise
électrique au modèle de bagnols et c'est
sans que les citoyens aient voté
forcément ses délégations ça aussi je
trouve que c'est un faux débat excusez
moi je dire les chefs d'états qui ont
voté ces délégations accepter ces
délégations sont élus par leurs parents
par leurs peuples de dire que c'est
bruxelles qui gouverne c'est typiquement
l'argument qu'on entende toutes les
trois minutes pour dire que c'est
illégitime non c'est pas illégitime et
un parlement à bruxelles et les autres
sont détachés par leur propre la
commission obéit à ce que lorsque
demande et c'est l'état mais je conçois
que c'est le plus important ça c'est le
modèle libéral ayez le modèle
souverainiste qui est à des années
lumières de ça c'est l'europe des
nations qui co qui collaborent sur un
certain nombre de thèmes mais pas sur ce
que chaque nation déciderait que s'est
séparé franck apprécié les migrations
on s'en sortirait pas on reviendrait au
excusez moi au modèle de l'europe de la
fin du 19ème de ces grandes puissances
qui cohabitent entre elles du mieux
possible et on est à des années lumières
alors il les rassure et fait réagir
bruno daroux de ces coopérations
renforcées qui se substituerait au
projet d'europe fédérale ou fédérale i
c'est l'alliance en tout cas les projets
de coopération militaire avec
l'allemagne et bien même si la marine le
pen n'en veut plus écoutée
l'allemagne s'affirme ainsi comme le
négatif absolue de l'identité
stratégique française fondée sur
l'indépendance la dissuasion est un
modèle d'armée et industriel complet de
rang mondial
prenante de ces différences de fond qui
sont des divergences stratégiques
irréconciliables
nous arrêterons l'ensemble des
coopérations avec berlin avions de
combat comme charges du futur pour
poursuivre nos propres programmes de
remplacement du char leclerc et du
rafale
j'arrêterai également le soutien
français à la revendication allemande
d'un siège permanent au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies et voilà
envoyé pour l'allemagne qui venait juste
pourtant de monter en puissance dans ses
investissements pardon en matière
militaire justement en matière de
défense bruno daroux ça pourrait
saborder le couple franco allemand bon
ça pourrait quand même
sérieusement compliquer les relations
puis d'ailleurs sur ces investissements
réellement à leurs proches à l'allemagne
de d'acheter des f-35 américain et non
pas d'acheter européen mais oui arrêter
la coopération militaire avec
l'allemagne ça créerait des tensions
très fortes entre paris et berlin et
donc ça secours et l'ensemble de l'union
européenne parce que même si elle dit
que le moteur franco allemand est devenu
c'était quoi sans exception quasi
fiction voilà est devenu une quasi
fiction non c'est pas une quasi fiction
par ailleurs alors pour tempérer un peu
elle dit non mais par contre on peut
renforcer notre amitié avec l'allemagne
sur la langue alors voudrait qu'on
apprenne le français et l'allemand plus
en europe pour sortir de la domination
de la langue anglaise renforcer la
coopération culturelle renforcée
l'office franco allemand de la jeunesse
bon c'est très bien enfin bon on voit
que la pilule serait quand même très
difficile à avaler pour berlin et sur
l'europe les mesures qu'elle propose qu
elle dit qu'elle veut rester dans
l'europe mais mesure qu'elle propose si
on pense à la à la primauté du droit
national sont le droit européen la
baisse de 5 milliards 1 la contribution
française au budget européen enfin vous
voyez qu'on partirait tout de suite des
choses qui restent totalement à
l'encontre des règles voire parfois des
traités européens donc oui ce serait en
tout cas un premier pas sur le sur le
ferai qu'une forme de fric si toi zé
l'imam
c'est un bras d'honneur à l'allemagne
encore une fois il est logique qu'ils
aient que je veux pas mal y est je veux
pas avoir les mains de la souveraineté
je veux pas que programme militaire avec
mais en même temps moi je suis assez
surpris par la violence du tout voir que
on a un problème aujourd'hui qui est
plutôt la russie qui est plutôt que
c'est notre voisin pour l'éternité de
comment on va gérer cette comment va
gérer cette puissance comme on va gérer
une relation et que ça et d'un seul coup
le couple franco allemand devient the
sun est aux abois ça sort un peu comme
un missile là aussi et d'un seul coup
les anglais dans sa lecture en fait
c'est l'allemagne qui domine et la
france est mise parce que l'allemagne
entre en piste finalement de oui oui
c'est une allemagne aux mines jusqu'à un
certain point à l'allemagne à ces
problèmes l'allemagne est dans une
situation stratégique très compliqué à
cause de la crise ukrainienne
l'allemagne à ses doutes et là vous
arrivez vous leur rentrer dedans comme
ça et je pense pas je pense que les
électeurs français ont aussi un peu
besoin d'être assurés juste une demi
phrase là dessus sur la russie par
exemple il ya beaucoup de gens en france
pas beaucoup mais il ya une certaine
partie des joueurs en france qui
préférait une situation stabilisée avec
la russie parce qu'ils ont peur parce
que c'est assez effrayant dans la vie
quotidienne cette guerre à nos portes
les missiles les possibilités nucléaire
etc ça et puis il ya des gens qui sont
femme assez fondamentalement pro-russe
et donc son discours il n'est pas
totalement
autonome blues qu'elle parle à des gens
qui sont un peu aligné
sur la même idée donc c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça que de temps en temps on
la soupçonne d'aller un petit peu
un peu loin c'est ancré 21 mai ce qui
est juste intéressant en deux mots c'est
que quand même parce qu'elle a fait
aujourd'hui ce discours comme de
l'étranger parce que c'est aussi c'est
quand même assez inédit dans les
élections présidentielles françaises la
première fois que les que les enjeux
internationaux jouent un rôle aussi
important
c'est important de le rappeler et merci
de dire merci beaucoup bruno daroux
merci via l'imam c'est la faim dont va
plus loin rester avec nous on se
retrouve pour la suite de paris direct
dans cinq minutes